can you believe what's going on did you
ever think in your lifetime you'd see
something like this I said it's like
living in an alternate I'm from the
generation that just come out of World
War two I'm the spirit that they showed
you know we'll do whatever is necessary
we'll all pull together and we'll try
and stay happy and that spirit it's kind
of what they needed and it's what we
need now and it is around you know
that's that's what we're seeing now that
a lot of people are pulling together and
in a way it's a great thing because if
we don't we're finished you know but it
is good to see that it's inspiring yeah
I'm reading a book now it's about world
war two and these guys who are just
incredibly rugged they band together
they're at least in the United States
you know during World War two everybody
was just they thought of as one they
knew what the enemy was and everybody
sacrificed I don't know you think we're
gonna see this are you gonna are we
gonna see like wild in the streets like
a civil unrest I know you mean because
when it started I thought oh god here we
go you know people are just gonna go
crazy you're gonna go loot in and what I
think from what I can see it's happening
the other way people are realizing that
there's so much good in humanity and I
think you know thank God it seems to be
showing itself everyone's you know doing
their best to stay safe and look after
each other and stuff and there is a lot
of lot of good spirit I hope you're safe
and sound your treasure and I don't want
any coronavirus getting near you I'm
going to tell the coronavirus myself
stay away from Paul we need them well
everyone is coping and staying safe and
keeping some optimism in these dark days
because the clouds will roll away